Okay.
We're just the little over a week out from
the first democratic,
it's and once again, the polls continue to
move in fascinating ways.
And I want to add something to our analysis
today, which are the prediction markets rather
than the polls.
And I'll explain that in a second.
So let's first look at what's happening with
the polls.
There are now some very clear trends and these
trends date back six or seven weeks.
Uh, Joe Biden six or seven weeks ago, hit
is high point in polling, averaging about
42% in the Democratic primary poles.
And it has been a steady and continued decline
forum dropping initially to about 35 then
34 33, uh, and further drops over the weekend
now to an average of 32 with one poll as low
as 27.
So things not looking great for Joe Biden.
And early on in Joe Biden's declines, the
declines were basically becoming Bernie's
gains, but that has leveled out for Bernie.
More recently, Joe's declines have been Elizabeth
Warren's gains.
Remember that she was pulling only four to
5% at the start of all this and has very slowly
but steadily climbed a point or a point and
a half per month.
And again, spiking this weekend, Elizabeth
Warren now averaging 11.2% in all recent polls,
a much more solid front runner at this point
in time.
And then also continuing to make small gains
is p booted judge now averaging just under
eight close to Elizabeth Warren.
And then Carla Harris keeps fading.
She was up to about 13% in February or March
and she's had this slow but steady decline
to under seven now.
So the trends that we started observing six
to eight weeks ago or continuing, nothing
has reversed them so far.
And then this is the point where people have
started writing in and saying, but, but, but
David, what about instead of looking at polls,
look at prediction markets where people bet
on who they think will win rather than just
saying who they plan to vote for because those
can be more accurate than the actual poles.
Well, let's do it.
And interestingly enough, the prediction markets
look very similar.
Predict id.org uh, predict it.
Dot Org rather rather predict it.
Dot Org is one and it has Joe Biden leading
Elizabeth Warren in second place, followed
closely by Bernie in third.
So that's a flip from the Poles where Bernie
is second and Warren is third.
Then you've got booted judge.
I mean these are basically the same numbers
as what the polls say.
Another prediction market predict wise has
it very similar with just a few tweaks.
Biden at 29, Warren at 15.
Budaj edge 14, Bernie 12 Kahmilah 11.
So again, very similar by one or two percentage
points.
The order is a little bit different.
So for everybody who's writing into me saying,
David, you've got to stop looking at polls.
And you need to start looking at the prediction
markets because we're the money is, it tells
us way more about what is going to happen
than where the Poles are.
Well, uh, the prediction markets see, uh,
the numbers relatively similarly.
They, they, they say that Biden is ahead and
that the front runners behind Biden seem to
be Elizabeth Warren.
Bernie Sanders booted judge Harris in varying
orders.
So what I'm more interested in seeing is when
the debates start, will we see a reversal
in any of these trends?
And what we also have to talk about today
is another polling issue, which is that a
new poll has Bernie Sanders plus nine over
Donald Trump in a hypothetical matchup and
Joe Biden plus 10 over Donald Trump.
I want to talk about that next.